okay so this is part two of The Winter
Marathon I clearly did not play the
whole thing is this fun working okay
there's some lag there
um I ended the stream earlier like very
early this morning in 30 something place
and since then I've dropped about 800
places
so thankfully I've gotten some sleep
and try and come back fresh
try and get a streak
um I'm currently not on a streak because
uh my last game I did lose which
prompted me to end the Stream
so playing this move order we have an
Italian
um with H3 early I like to go for this
G5 G4 break
hey it's h Posey
I still owe some opening requests to
I've yet to play ponziani or Evans
Gambit
wow
take take
and this looks good for black
but it also looks crazy
um King takes I have Rook G8
there's also there's ideas of targeting
H3 as well
um but then Queen after three
Queen D7
[Music]
I really like to make this work somehow
starting with Rook G8
so King H2 I have Knight G4
wow
okay let's take a pawn
threading Bishop G4
and threatening The Rook
I imagine a lot of my opponents
will be a little bit tired
and maybe fatigued and hallucinating
so I have to use that to my advantage uh
oh I love Knight T5
maybe I'm also kind of tired
okay
yeah Queen F6 was not the musical
thought I'll move
I should probably just go for some sort
of a simplification
I take on E3 Knight T4
up material
welcome back to more people
foreign
I would like to take
I have Knight takes and then Knight T4
Pawn digs maybe Queen H4
the problem is it's hard to develop my
queen
because it's controlling this and this
although now I have Queen A5
this is still a threat
maybe a castle
[Music]
maybe Rook
defending the pawn preventing that F6
Queen covers C7 and pins the pawn
so I think it's it's okay here
now the pawn is no longer pinned but it
kind of is through x-ray vision
also I may have missed Ricky one
I probably should have played Rook G1
there would be a line where like I take
the rook and then like King is actually
I've been in trouble
[Music]
like I don't know if I want to take the
Rook
take
I think it's safer not to
okay Knight B3
I should have played Knight B3
okay so I win The Rook like that
okay getting the job done
some time to spare
well it's not blunder H6
foreign
oh dear
yes yes
okay
oh dear okay that's a wake-up call
oh wow
I got so relaxed there it was such a
relaxing position and then
all chaos broke loose
not berserking this person
let's try and let's try and play a clean
game
what a game to start to stream
hi Eric been away for a while how is
your Cambridge Springs course going it's
going it's uh it's a lot of work
what so hopefully I'll have an update
soon Marathon streams are awesome
welcome back to Lafayette
unfortunately my watch I think is dead
don't have my heart rate monitor
for now would have been nice for that
last game
and G4
G4 essentially wins upon
G5
each for coming threading mates
oh fancy
um I think I'll play F4
so that was like a fancy trade
still up a pawn
C5 might be coming
C5 might actually win the pawn back
of a fair move
I Bishop E2
the C5 I take
so black can choose which Pawn
like Rook
how to do this
like a3b4
a knight is misplaced play rookie one
first
finding some kind of
funny business against the night
I might be threatening Knight D5
actually
followed by Bishop D3
hey it's germano right as janano welcome
back to mano
happy deja vu 42 months of deja vu
I'll have to go through like all my old
streams and make a compilation of
every time zamana Subs
so much deja vu
okay I think I'm winning more material
here
like Knight F5
how to do this though
okay I'll start with taking
the pong was overworked
if it takes takes
I just wants some scope against F7 Pawn
okay
in B3
this is pretty solid
up two Pawns
Rook D2 I have Rook C3
so here it's just a matter of not
getting too careless
um do I want to allow the trade
um
I mean I forgot six
I think workout six and C6
nice move
and Rook D2 ADV Rook C5
so now I'm basically gonna I'm
guaranteed to win the a pawn
because both Rooks defend
and now in my apologian flourish
might as well defend G5
some calculation
[Music]
okay
trying to stay clean this stream
uh two in a row
that was a cleaner game
it was a matter of winning material
early
some middle game trickiness
got the job done also a matter of
declining the draw yeah
I won't play a four nights
this is a so-called Schmid defense
it's a tricky line one of my um pet
openings for Blitz
and the sign actually just wins upon her
back
up a clean Pawn
extra Pawn is doubled so
um
it still takes a lot of work to win
but it's a pretty risk-free position
my Bishop B4
some weak dark squares here
question about more Marathon streams for
next year
yeah every year there is typically four
big Marathon tournaments
so
[Music]
what the spring summer autumn and winter
I think I've played most of them this
year
not sure if I missed one or two
but I usually make an effort to play if
I'm available
[Music]
as I miss Bishop B3 I think I did
um now it trades because or maybe maybe
I win the pawn six months a few months
ago your calm videos helped me as a
prepped for Business School interviews I
didn't get in but the stream helped my
nerves nonetheless
thanks for the wholesome message
Kodiak iron
appreciate that
I think I want to put the Rook on V4 and
then play C4
a simple plan
okay H5 looks nice
keeping an eye on the weaknesses
could play C4 here maybe C6 first
to prepare the eventual B5
and White's a bit stuck
I really just have to watch time
this is a typical pattern where the
pawns kind of expand and then contract
okay I found the maiden one
there we go
yeah this is a 24 hour long tournament
I've played maybe about four or five
hours worth
so trying I guess the goal is to finish
like top
top 100 I don't know that's possible
though
I think the top 500 get like some
Marathon trophy
virtual reward
okay this is a Mainline Theory
um there's a few moves here for lock
Knight E7
can I take
H4 first
uh
I take
a little bit confused what's happening
but The Bishop's trapped now
this is the drawback to the Knight being
on E7
so it looks like this is working out
and rookout 4 didn't really help that
just gave me more material
yeah this should be a pretty
straightforward win
especially now because the Knight is
pinned to the queen of Knight B5 I take
and then take the bishop
yeah top 500 you get trophies
question about duck chess
it'd be nice if uh there was a
a duck chess Marathon
I'd love to play that
24 hours of quacking
cause for all the relaxing and
insightful content oh my pleasure thank
you mondal
okay a five coming
yeah so now the G files open
[Music]
I'm just trying to make quickly
threading made into
that is no longer pinned
hmm
I guess a cool meeting ideas Rook G7
take and then mate
foreign
I pre-moved Rook H6
but uh okay
pretty smooth game
trying to work my way back up in the
world
playing puzzle fanatic
I have a digital opening any tips for
recovering after a bad loss in a
tournament
um
sometimes it's a matter of experience
and having the right mindset
um
yeah like the more games you lose the
more
you'll learn how to cope with losses
but it can help to
actually try and like reflect on what
went wrong
because usually losses are a result of
like multiple mistakes not just one
mistake
so if you can try and find the root
cause of the mistake or the mistakes
then
hopefully that will make you a stronger
player
okay what's happening here reminds me of
the first game I played in this stream
got the pawn to F3
and I'll take on G2
I think this is a better version though
D4 is kind of hanging
I have four attackers against D4
so let's take it
F2 should be a Target very soon
also the F3 Square could be
used by the Knight
so I'm holding onto the behind the thing
is the point kind of acts as a shield to
the white king
so
yeah it's still not easy to break
through
in one potential idea
is some eventual Queen H2 and promotes a
queen with mate oops I just hang up on
I hung more than a pawn
as he hung my whole Queen side
I just miss the queen good move down
I was too focused on my g-pawn
I think it's still okay
it wasn't necessary though
that was equal material
both kings are questionable
[Music]
yeah probably something I got six
foreign
[Music]
I'm in trouble here
very possibly loses
um
active King though
wow
and white is flirting with Danger
in this Amaze I found these
okay
oh that was kind of close
I guess I'll take it I'll take it
[Music]
okay another wake-up call
what just happened
he'll be just spazzing after that last
game
come on berserk again
playing rodri
the Rosen is back
I'm back I'm slightly more awake
thankfully
welcome back to everyone
leech School
lead school yeah
hopefully Queen D2
controlling the center
yeah the setup is slightly questionable
like there's bound to be some Center for
trick for black
and Bishop should be on D3
in 95 coming
I'm trying to make this work
like h4h5
I don't mind like doubling the d-pawns
oh I do mine that though
oh wow
uh that's big trouble
[Music]
it's actually like really big trouble
I also Castle greenside
yeah that's a pretty bad oversight
okay I'm trying something
we've seen Miracles before
that's great life advice
so I'm down a minute and down the piece
hmm
Chuck
I'm trying to get some confusion here
foreign
y two
three wants to be on D3
and Knight can come to E2 F4 a Target G6
now this pawns pinned
thank you
so I won that material and more
rookie one saves me
I'm not over yet though
foreign
came back that's nice
playing a submega
and berserking will continue
[Music]
trying to keep up the streak
if I've gone from like 800 something to
now 690
still over three hours to go
some gradual play here
Rook should be on D1 Queen should be on
D2
Bishops should be on C4
the online pieces could use some
improving
maybe take that
and some E5
[Music]
moving a little bit too slow here
should also be considering a bit about
seven
or E6
this E6 here
so it takes I had taken Fork
if takes on E6
see what's happening here
um
thank you
like so there's some plan of Queen G6
and then Knight G5
even Knight D6
yeah so the Bishops pinned The Rook
Rook is also tied down to defending the
bishop
I have seven ideas
okay I hit the queen so both Queens are
hanging
What's Happening Here
it's not so simple I got the Knight to
be one
wow
foreign
okay now it should be less confusing
5-15 seconds
what a game
I went for the first time to the chess
club yesterday and had a win with the
Stafford Gambit oh nice thank you for
teaching it to me my pleasure
keep it up and bomb
okay let's just simplify
how I meet with queen and Rook
that's how I mean okay I got confused
there for a moment
oh man
okay 666 lucky number
hey 667 even luckier
Magnus kasparo that's a terrifying name
ooh I should have played C5
oh what to do
calling it now Eric wins the next game
in 21 moves oh now I feel pressure
so much pressure
we have to play G6 and do it by five I
have to play aggressively
wait this game or the game after this
maybe the game after this
I can feel less pressure now
uh but I still feel time pressure
and b5a4
b5a5
so I'm calculating castling takes takes
takes
maybe bishop takes
and now there's this to deal with
threatening Rook A2
hmm
I don't think I'm gonna win in two more
moves here
but you never know
foreign
nice to have the Rook support the pawn
and I wants to come to C5 and maybe D3
foreign
and then push
it's a tactic to always be aware of
this whole trade a little bit
and expecting Ruger 5
oh
okay so now it defends a rook I think
that was a oversight from light
still tricky
threatening this B2 Pawn
maybe some kind of Bishop E5 F6 D4
configuration could be nice
this is how I control the center I put
all my things in the center
oh there's a funny mate King F3 Rook G3
means
uh oh Rook G3 isn't possible there
still trying to meet
there we go okay
not quite 21 moves but got the job done
so the streak continues oops
did I do
my knight C6
okay playing aggressively here
basically a reverse Grand Prix attack
and queen bees three I do have D5
and this should be okay
and bishop's a little bit out of it
foreign
making progress
yeah like the file is guaranteed to open
the problem for white is F2 Pawn
can't easily be defended because I
controlled F1 square with the bishop
and there's really no preventing either
capture
although I guess G4 is a move
wow
F3
or takes and then takes
it's the best way to do this
it's even E3 right
uh
this is probably the safer choice
you're not completely winning yet
you like C5
be nice to have the um the bishop play a
role
hmm
uh I love my G4
oops
I might be in some trouble here
even though it still looks okay
I still want to play C5
[Music]
I wasn't sure
foreign
uh
wow
okay somehow I've I'm checkmating
it's actually crazy that
in this position
[Music]
I didn't immediately see how light
defends G3
because like Queen F2 I take the bishop
so is it already like
better for black
a king could run I guess but
his wife have any move
greetings from Mars
yeah it's not easy is both the prime and
the concatenation of the primes two and
three oh the next such Prime is 37 a
number popular with director Kevin Smith
oh interesting
thanks for the fun fact
I'll come back hold water
okay that was a very close game
so I'm still undefeated this uh this
stream
try and keep up the streak chasing 2500
again
my rating took a large zip
the previous stream
okay we have London
so C6 D6
and just develop
the ambition D3
no E5 is uh
lightly move
upon them taking a long time in the
opening which is nice
try and make up some of my time deficits
already threatening Nichi 5
I have A5 then the G5 I think is strong
that's a move of course
and that's not so happy here
also there's pawns under attack
but this Pawn's hanging I don't know
what's going on here
um
okay so I'm up upon
still not the most Pleasant position
but okay it's something I think I can
work with all the work dates coming
yeah losing the exchange
foreign
if you're just joining this is a
marathon tournament
I'm uh
I'm trying not to lose I'm actually in a
lot of trouble here
I have to say a little bit focused
uh
yeah this is not pleasant oh this is
really not pleasant
G3 a G5 is coming
this is gonna be my first loss of the
stream unfortunately
oh
unless there's some trickery
foreign
trickery let's go
okay I'm still undefeated this stream
what a funny stalemate
I was thinking about just resigning
because it doesn't seem like the king
would be standing in the center
but
he was to give away all the Pawns
shallow tagari thanks for reading in a
nice that's a boy funny moment
thank you shallow wizard
oh that's such a funny track too
there's a lot of moves that like sail
names every sign
um like this move
really just two moves that stalemate
actually
okay I'll take it
top 600 wait what
why does it still say five
I should have gotten like two points for
that
I'm confused
maybe it didn't update
anyway yeah if you're just joining
um I'm about 50 minutes into the Stream
and I did do a like four to five hour
stream last night
uh which is the first kind of
quest in this Marathon
but this is a final quest
trying to finish as high as possible
hopefully top 500.
maybe higher
um
yeah this position isn't like so great
but it's playable
yeah this Pawn
[Music]
hoping this Pawn is more weak than it is
strong
Eric dates
foreign
welcome back
um 95
obstructing the queen
I guess this is just trading though
yeah this is just a big train
oh my phone preserved too so now it's
just basically a bullet game
I got the D file the only open file
which is quite nice
[Music]
I want to play Rook C2
and before I take and then play A4
I think C4
I think this is okay
better be okay
now it's a classic situation where I
have the outside passer
so the king will be closer to the rest
of the Pawns
um
this is the quickest way
okay
that was a nice game
nice uh
end game happening there
I don't understand the scoring system
do I get five points for the stalemate
foreign
like that I deserve the Five Points
okay another game
oh did my appointment get banned really
that's so funny if my opponent got
banned
maybe that's why I've
I got such a bad position
wait let me check my um
usually it will notify me though
uh I wanna taking is okay Queen E7 check
95 check
um it should be two maybe
the queen
wow
[Music]
I've only got banned
back to tournament
you lost to someone who violated leeches
TOS refunds of four Blitz rating points
okay that's nice
and I got this family Trap on top of
that
so I didn't lose my streak oh that's
nice
oh wait it says I lost to someone though
even though I drew someone
and especially even though it feels like
I won with that uh with what happened
yeah I think my opponent just got banned
because
uh they allowed the stalemate
oh this looks fun
wait a minute
take on a five
foreign
Bishop G5 which is not the easiest thing
to stop
oh wow black started
but the checks will continue
[Music]
the other Bishop wants to join the party
season trophy still stands too
oh that's nice
yeah so the game isn't like removed from
history
I would hope
yeah the problem for black is this King
short on squares
uh let's take
Queen E6 mates
is coming
okay a couple quick wins there
so yeah and a nice streak of fives
I'm going for a Budapest Gambit
uh let's take usually Knight takes I
play this
Queen D4
here E4 looks nice
wow opponent just resigns
and it's playable for white 95. why am I
even like be completely okay
okay A3
a black is is for choice
I'll take it seven move win
I feel like I just won like
three games in the span of
maybe four or five minutes
hey I'm back I'm back to 2500. I'm
berserking someone
above 2500
so this will take some Focus
everything G4 already
[Music]
um
I have six ideas
quack
thanks for the quack
ing this now
Eric Familia
I'm not quite working
queen of four
foreign
this looks crushing but it still takes a
bit of work
D7 might be a threat this would be five
looks nice
foreign
to take on D7
I'm just going for it
and this and after it takes takes the
Knight is trapped
if calcium greenside is made in one
and just play this move
allowing 98 but after a bishop Bishop to
E5
and Knight G5 coming
it's too much fun though
yeah the attack is Raging
hey I won in 21 moves who called it
earlier that I was gonna win the 21
moves
it took a few games more than expected
though
okay 470.
staying clean
my name is Starry Papa's
foreign
let's go for Cambridge Springs
I don't think I've played the Cambridge
Springs
you got this tournament uh this is a
nice looking move
there's also B6
usually C5 is a bit premature
hmm
not so simple
I think it was too risky to win the pong
white sock tonight for a check
ing is a little bit precarious
foreign
but it should be safe
I have that file
E4 is a good move
because E4 makes my life a little bit
easier too
even though it opens the center
problem for white is a rook can't access
E1
also I have initiative
and I can keep harassing the queen
in Bishop A6 at some points even C5
well my opponents see the main threat
ah they saw it
English Basics now
if I need to take and then take
with H3 Queen G3 threading the bishop
and mates
g3i could take it
again controlling E1
and there is this move
maybe E5
anytime I could just
trade into an end game up two Pawns
but I'd rather go for a mating attack
like Rook Rook d8
ooh
foreign
25 seconds
winning a lot of Pawns here
there's potential G5 mates
I need more
I pre-move the rest of the game
let's remove the rest of the game
door my thing
okay let's not pre-move the rest of the
game let's just try and win
it's trying to have a little bit too
much fun there
okay
not the cleanest finish but uh there's a
finish nonetheless
maybe I missed a fork
okay top 450 berserking will continue
[Music]
two and a half hours left
have an English opening double berserk
wow
it's like the vampire type opening
I want green B3 yeah
this bishop should be a bit preferable
especially if I can get in C5 B6
this bishop has no legal moves
foreign
I would like to trade off into
a bishop ending
like Queen trade would be nice
I'm winning a pong would also be nice
foreign
G4 May Come
G4 Queen G3
hmm
okay
another one down four eleven
playing sea costume
I just have to take it one game at a
time
another London
this is a fun line it might be five
I think 96.
trying to remember how it goes
and D6
and black is still okay with proper play
I can't take his Queen A5 check
Bishop
two years happy holidays Eric and chat
happy two years six TV
appreciate that
and I'd see it is kind of coming a
little next year no I just take on C4
thank you
Bishop H5 is looming
hmm
and go for The Rook lift
okay now Bishop H5 is more of a threat
F4
[Music]
okay sacking the bishop maybe I should
take first and then F5
foreign
's going to be very close to promoting
like Queen G8 I take and then F7 and
then f8 oh but Richie two
um
foreign
play this
allowing Rook G2 King F1 and then F7
yeah a nice really misplaced here
foreign
looking at Bishop F6
oh man
I think you roll away
happy eight months
okay
[Music]
foreign
yeah sorry I don't have the heart rate
monitor the Stream
next time
thank you
so Bishop D3 there's a takes
and the queen is already facing some
troubles here
um
might as well take
welcome back protest's Daddy
appreciate the bits
oh blueberry Mike found me through the
or from the call and ambulance clip
there were there were many Colin
ambulance clips
many ambulances were called
I don't think I've said that phrase this
stream though
or the previous stream
I have to watch my time here
I like the opening of The Thing white
has managed to consolidate
it should still be a little bit better
the structure
D5 might come
um
foreign
maybe C4
and king cafe would be nice to throw in
not sure if I can get a way of taking
the pawn
I think king of eight first
would be seven coming
foreign
[Music]
a few times
but that's okay
oh man
I don't think I missed a fork
Knight G4 was an idea but I was pinned
so that's why I played King G7
[Music]
um man
tricky game
okay let's go for E5
maybe have a chance for Greek gift there
I mean H6 is maybe ooh
um
still threatening this
and that's provoking me
calculating King G6
it's actually not so simple
Queen G4
probably Queen G4
oh
okay this is simple
okay that was nice
still moving up 331
approaching 300 tournament points
dessert
a London opening
foreign
here
have a Carlsbad structure
hmm
foreign
this is a pretty typical maneuver
by Knight D5
could walk into A3
take take
still going for it
a lot of Trades
and bishop's not too impressive here
maybe F6
idea Rook C4
foreign
oh no
There Goes My Rook
er down here
foreign
I hope you have good snacks
I had breakfast earlier
okay for now
apart from this position
[Music]
foreign
flag
oh
I love the queen trade somehow yeah
grow a cheese okay
well the streak continues
I really should have lost that
just a little bit quicker towards the
end there
did I miss Sports meet oops
and to go back
I'll leave chat though
but that was a more exciting finish
right then
just checkmate
got the heart pumping
if I remember like later I can go back
and look
it's Castle Queensland
some idea to play Queen G5 and Knight F5
[Music]
now they'd used to play Pawn G5
upon F5
okay so 95 oh wow
and maybe I should not have allowed that
huh
in some trouble here
thank you
again
I think if I'm still on the horizon
not sure if this actually does anything
[Music]
he went upon
yeah we're trading them
foreign
nose to sticky keys
no
oh man
I don't know if I was playing for a win
or a draw towards the end there
in there okay
I was in trouble that game and I was
down the pond and then somehow a pulling
gave back a lot of Pawns
playing Ferraris oh it's berserk
and white moves first okay
ah
[Music]
try and recover here
this is a very um
slower positional type line
um
I'd like to go for Queen E2 first
preventing this uh minority attack
okay trying to clamp down
so the goal is to play Knight D2 to B3
to C5
foreign
s for New Years
good question
um
I should make some
as of now I mean maybe I'll stream
I could do a New Year's stream
but maybe I'll just uh
make it easy
have some tea
focus on my resolutions
foreign
this is not so easy
okay
foreign
[Music]
it's so close though
are you really close
okay now it went up on
did I lose it back
foreign
I'm in trouble
yeah I'm getting or am I
maybe I'm not
ah
how's it feel free move
foreign
a little bit too long time there
wasn't in the rates
mind space
okay
um nope is working let's uh in China not
lose the second game in a row that's the
first loss of the Stream
and
93 minutes in
um let's play Bishop D6
Castle rookie eight
some plans to play E5
if white plays slowly
okay this is basically a reverse London
now
um very positional very solid for both
sides
preventing Bishop A3
though it might be hard to prevent
like Queen E6 Bishop B8
maybe G5 at some point
hmm
maybe I should trade Bishops
now it's Bishop was actually doing well
on E3
and Knight T3 coming
okay
I think this still calls for like very
patient play
okay now G5
[Music]
being slightly impatient
idea Queen G6
later ideas maybe like each five H4
yeah we're gonna get some
probably some Rook ending at some point
oh Knight D4 coming it's about H5
H4
foreign
wow I just smother mated themselves
uh the smothered Fork meat was
unexpected
yeah I think it was it was basically
tunnel vision white was so focused on
getting the G file
I forgot about King safety
okay playing a simple line against
trumpowski
there's a move of G5 here but
actually G5 I don't think was playable
yeah she's going for E5
um I don't usually play these structures
but
we'll try and make it work
maybe C5
hoosings down
some F5 The Rook should be on
I meant to play Pawn V6 not Queen B6
Queen B6 is not a great Square for the
queen
how bad is it
I lost a couple Tempe
I mean maybe it's not so bad
black is definitely much worse here
though
it's still holding on
okay how to do this
I just want to generate some play
like if we trade at least I have the E5
Square now to work with
thank you
I'd use Bishop to D4
doesn't look so great though
I'll just defend the pawn
time is my biggest issue here
positions definitely improved
.
I'm going full Ham on the king side
Bishop C5 have Knight H4
ah that doesn't work oh no my Bishop
someone call an ambulance
the opponent sees the threat
oh no my Rook
that's really close to winning now
it's all about initiative
foreign
oh I can see that move
faster
there we go okay
oh that's not easy that's really not
easy
GG
oh
yeah I was in trouble that game
okay back on track
playing against a modern
kind of playing against a hippo
hey it's Irene what's up Irene
yeah this is like um
I know what we call this
and G6 E6 97
it kind of resembles the Sicilian now
but yeah it should be easier to play for
white
get away with D5
okay I completely forgot B2 is hanging
I don't think I can take the Knight
I want to but
it sure was just happened there
okay Chuck
good thing about 24 hours stream is that
us Europeans can catch Eric at a
reasonable time oh yeah that's true
trying to be friendly to every time zone
also trying not to flag here
I'm gonna do this
I don't even know what move to play
castling
I spend so much time on that move
gotta move a lot quicker I'm in trouble
here
three
okay let me see four
I want to get get the Knight away but
yeah
okay two
foreign
thank you
can be stopped
ah
I need chances
the problem was
was Queen B7
it's actually crazy position I can't
stop the pawn
again
that was a fun one
this wasn't wasn't quick enough
or strong enough
okay trying to break into the top 300.
I think I beat this opponent earlier
yeah that game
we'll play one of these
uh let's play this
also quack
amen
thank you son rakasha
it's an F5
and this and this
so E3 is a potential Target 95
foreign
not the best choice
still gets crazy though
threatening rookie two
foreign
has so much more time
it probably just takes a few accurate
moves
but rookie two yeah that's a good move
I take
and take your let's take your first
foreign
it's actually really confusing
time is leveling
foreign
uh
I hung meat
and the goal is to check the king but
this one square off
good game though Eric I hope you are
doing well hello thanks as always for
the great content
thank you young Dairy
um okay I'll keep trying to
pommel away
yeah no need for predictions right now
at some point I'm going to try and like
rework Channel points this is at this
time I'm uh
reevaluating the channel Point Rewards
okay we have the signing in
which I may have had against the same
opponent
yeah it looks like block is neutralizing
ooh
okay well here I'm up upon
and the pawn that I'm up
looks pretty strong
I'm going straight for the throat
oh
F5 might be played
I was just looking at um
H6 Queen G6 which I think I'll go for
like the most aggressive way to play
this
I'm not sure if it works but
I think the fact that my Pawn covers
E7
is pretty useful because the king's not
gonna be able to escape
pandig's Knight is really the only
option here
hello to ratty
foreign
it's still weird though
in G4
it's actually really confusing
because Queen H4 doesn't do much just
loses the pawn
and just queenside castling
I didn't see the wind
I still have my d-pawn
black is still kind of stuck
I want to play F4 but there's on the
song
I want to play F4 duck F3
I have to take
check
huh
I wasn't sure
foreign
coming
okay
oops
I thought I was winning the Rope there
but okay it works out
nice Final Mate
there we go
yeah opponents are getting stronger
as I move up
2500 on the dots
Stafford Gava time
play 95
yeah this is a fun line
C6 it's already
a little bit problematic for lights
the center is kind of crumbling
I'm gonna still play in the spirit of
the staff Arena
ignite
but how to do it in Bishop F5 first
I go for like Queen H4 casting Queen
side
and then the Raging attack
if G3 I think king or queen
F6 maybe Queen D4 even
some issue with e-file
try Queen D4
an interesting looking position
okay so I'm back to being down upon
uh
that's not good let's play this
I might be losing a piece too
but what's happening
and Bishop D1 Bishop D1 I take on C4 and
D2
hmm
and White's pawns are still menacing
wow
foreign
a very confusing sequence
thank you
Bishop B3 probably coming
but should be three I take on E7 though
still not out of danger because this
skewer thing
but I think it's okay
still down the pond
oh goodbye to Pam
yeah apologies it's hard to keep an eye
on chat
the things to people tuning in stopping
by
the dust is settling here wow no the
dust is
blowing in my face
but this bishop is trapped
okay
I was uh that was a confusing game
wow so I'm going to break 300 in both
directions
with tournament points and placing
hopefully
I should mix up the openings too
uh this is F6
okay
no mercy no mercy
hey I broke 300. 274 304 tournament
points
that's why you should never play F6
but speaking of F6
let's hold off for a moment
maybe I'll play it eventually
oh
I should not have a lot of that
yeah when I do this
you guys should have played F6
I can take
okay so we have some
equal material situation my Bishop might
be getting trapped
yeah G4 coming
not losing material it just gets kind of
ugly takes takes takes takes
what's happening Bishop G2
it's an H5
looks okay up a pawn I mean all my pawns
are doubled like all my Pawns
but I have six of them
three sets of double Pawns
uh yeah light spinning upon back
play this maybe before
can try and double white spawns
I want to play Rook H3
some activity
foreign
wow
what a cool position I have 22 seconds
I'm just realizing Knight c8's playable
a Bone's gonna play it but I have G
G pawn move coming
can I see it was missed this Rook is
just stuck
oh why'd I do that
hi Eric
hi
I just gave away my whole position
[Music]
now what to do
a new steel Matrix
you never know though
things got weird sometimes
uh what should I do
oh it's a cool game
had my chances it looked really good
around here I probably shouldn't trade
off the night
also nightsy it was playable for many
many moves there
okay
277.
I'm gonna take it one game at a time
foreign
not to waste time in the opening on like
especially on positions where I know the
theory
A5 idea
it was a pawn
causing Mayhem
you can see Queen yeah so Knight A5 is
the final straw
a nice London opening
14 movement
it's nice having the quick games like
that
doesn't happen all the time
but when it does I should be grateful
okay got this sign
I'm going to play this like a Stafford
if that's even possible
I just Chuck the Knight
sagging it for the h file
it's a complete Bluff but
sometimes the reason for doing this it
does make the opponent think
and even if white does take
then it leads to an easy position to
play
because I have like one idea
so we get this instead
not down any material we might be
trading D for epong
or not
um
that's a double attack
still attacking things
I'm still tempted to play this move I
think I will
even though it's not really called for
it just looks kind of fun
and didn't take the piece the first time
the problems broke out for
so I'm down the bishop
I guess I got what I wanted
um
I Rook H6
foreign
wait what
oh I just gave the Rook
let's move
this should be over very soon
okay don't pay off
I've been hovering around 2500.
almost top 250 back on the streak
still some
places to climb
playing this person again ah this person
remember this game
play a different line here
some sort of like benoni structure
thank you
I'm trying to play a lot of quick moves
here
and queen B4 is sometimes interesting
threatening the e-pawn
thank you
going for B5
which unfortunately is not so simple to
achieve
uh
what do I even do here in this move
this would be five
a little bit low in space
oh dear
okay I do want to trade
see four
now let's take
a blunder the pawn
not looking so good
foreign
[Music]
G4 kh7
uh
mm-hmm
oops
I just hung their book
ah what to do difficult position phone
played well
okay
yeah the um
the opponents get tougher like as I move
up in the standings
I think the position wasn't great from
the opening that game
let's mix things up I'll play E4
let's go for um
one of these
should be two
Queen B6
some idea Knight D6
I just saw 95 it's not good although 95
it's actually a poison Pawn I think
I'm just stumbling into tactics
there is A6
and this one's material
man that was a pretty Savage night
we just took all the Box pieces
okay
um
Budapest has been serving me decently
well
it leads to some crazy positions
this is a little bit less crazy
[Music]
and the goal of Queen E7 is to prevent
life from castling
which I think does the trick
it's all about creating initiative
against the setup
maybe I should have played Knight T5
do I want to play F6 I guess I guess I
do
well that's Queen B3 but then Bishop E6
even Queen B3 King h8
thank you
allowing each three
yeah Knight C6 was a little bit careless
[Music]
I am berserking almost every game
and a tournament like this I'm I'm
trying to finish high in the standings
so
it's uh
it's part of the tournament strategy
play this move
now I'm just confused
I'm talking upon
uh White can probably Castle here
oh wow
foreign
[Music]
yeah this is
probably just worse for buck
let me simplify a bit too
foreign
but I'm losing C7 probably
Bishop B7
yeah d5's a Target
wait what
oh
okay that I've
missing a lot of things there but it
works out
that's going to be a time scramble
time is leveling
go after the sea Pawn
rookie one I'll probably take it
make a triple battery
thank you
really passive here
trying to be passive aggressive
threatening made in two or not meets but
guy win the queen
okay got the job done
passive aggressiveness paid off
okay
climbing up
trying to break top 200.
I didn't make note of how many players
are playing this tournament also the
leader has exactly a thousand points
which is pretty crazy
okay so the bishop plays a nice role
preventing block from castling I'm
sacking upon
but there should be compensation
I didn't actually intend to trade Queens
but
it's still okay
black still has some issues to solve
I'll keep improving
I feel like F4 F5
B3 for good measure
and no Trading
um
yeah B6 is coming
that's a good move
and go for
group H1
[Music]
not blunder
B3 Bishop B2
Ah that's a gray move
I am in trouble
and a lot of trouble here
still fighting
there's some F5
B4
funny idea to get the bishop to f8
there's about five is an idea now
it was on over
there we go
okay
it's a draw had chances there
a little bit low on time
uh playing this person again who beat me
earlier
what was the game earlier
take my chances again
going for this sign
[Music]
um
I can see six Bishop five
this already looks Pleasant for black
okay
foreign
yeah I'd like to punish white somehow
for this
you see five
and G5 even
allowing Knight D5
wow
that's not so simple
oh it's really not so simple
I should probably just resign
foreign
there's it's set up pretty well for the
Trap so let's try it
take take take please
I tried
I tried to give enough time
by opponents knew what was up
okay
while playing
still over an hour left
win rate of 68 percent
let me try and raise that
okay playing Andrew
yeah going for double fing hello
positional line
in 95 Rook C8
D5
well I'll play E5 here
take the Knight first
and then win the bishop
okay and one a piece and we're
simplifying completely
and I don't think I'm getting mated
foreign
I think the goal is to
attack F2
I already have the triple battery lined
up
I also just want oop and this is a free
Pawn at first
uh play this move
foreign
took a little bit of work
there we go
playing Arc shock oops I was a mouse
live
what fun opening can I play
blue Sicilian
foreign
very pleasant position here
um
foreign
probably didn't handle this in the best
regarding
let's close the center a little bit
King D2
I really don't like the way I'm playing
this
the fatigue is kind of setting in
but
it might be three
somehow it's still okay
I have to watch out for Queen G2
oops
it should still be okay
just joining the stream good luck
oh thank you
okay don't feel great about that but
I'll take it thank you celtress
we have uh
another game
new opponent hey it's Ben what's a pen
welcome welcome
shout out to Ben
uh
uh if you're just joining I'm kind of
tired
this is a long Marathon tournament
I played for several hours last night
into this morning
we are approaching the final hour of the
tournament
I'm in 226th place
out of I don't know how many people
[Music]
at some point I'll check
oh yeah I have to play F6 the scheme in
honor of Ben
also knife F4
yeah preparing F6 and knife F4
I got a big Ben proud
Merry Christmas from Santa hope you're
having a great festive season
thank you bakus
there's really no reason to play F6 in
this position
I think the
alternative plan is Pawn H5
or Bishop A6
okay I might miss the threat
is some C5 idea
and just a lot of D5
wow
I'm slightly confused these pawns should
be weak but they they're kind of like
defended
uh
F6 let's play this move
this Pawn is the most attackable
and maybe it like Knight F3 F5
kind of interesting
wow
I'll sack back material
I have 25 seconds what is this
I'm up upon about to maybe with another
Pawn hey F6
I think it wins a pong
always play F6
uh Queenie fry take
who has the emotes
the never play F6 emotes and the F6 bam
emoons
wow
wow okay
foreign
s
thank you nanny
wow the king is stopping the pawn
the king is just stuck in jail
what would Ben do Ben would under her
Motel like scored Bishop
okay
it was hard to under promote to a Dark
Sword Bishop there
at least with Athan
I wanted to deliver mate with a bishop
and then I realized like whenever I take
on C2 it's still made
Origins not checkmate
okay
okay working time
less than one hour left
a final stretch
I should stretch
okay
sometimes Bishop D3 E4
we might see a five
I guess not
now they'll apply on the C5 and get a
knight to D6
and G4 as well
I'm still down upon that there's there's
comp
that's basically a fork
foreign
okay that's a fork
oops
okay it's still in the material
okay
on the streak top 200
top 100 will be really difficult
like even if I went out it's probably
not guaranteed
I'll play one of these
I could have won the pond there actually
but this is a more enjoyable plan
and going for a quick meet
uh
Queen H4
and leave C7 hanging
right here
Knight C7 rookie three
there's some crazy line
okay I'm gonna just sack the knights
the point is after it takes takes
I want to play Bishop H3
hmm
doesn't quite work
yeah I'll just have to cut my losses
oh dear
this was going terribly wrong
always play off six
this is such a bad position
like just a failed Budapest
foreign
need
ah had my chances there life like
blundered all the things
that's crazy I had chances
not quite enough time
okay 199. I think top 150 is like a
realistic goal
but that requires like finishing strong
foreign
MP3
that's already Pleasant here
foreign
[Music]
good move
so 94 will come
should still be fine for white
foreign
G5 coming
okay the king will come to D3
and this should be like full domination
maybe E4
all right how do I break through
but the King on e4
slowly but surely
oops
got a lot of Pawn E4 for a moment there
black wasn't expecting it though
okay so I'm gonna put the Rook on E2
and now what
hmm
I don't want to like play 15 moves
before
okay I took work
there's probably a lot of
unnecessary moving around
here we go
got one of these
oh no my Bishop
yeah I guess I have to trade Queens
not a great position
and this
foreign
oh it's holding on there for a little
bit
okay
Full Tilt
from Gambit
accelerated from his gambits
uh what is this
take
this is a Full Tilt opening
foreign
we've reached the point where it's time
to like Gambit every game
have some fun
hey it's Kimmy Lou what's up Kimmy Lou
long time no see
you're just in time
to see my whole position crumble oh dear
I'm in trouble
take on each two maybe
yeah shout out to Kimmy hope you're
doing well
this is a really really bad position
[Music]
I'll play a few more moves
because berserking didn't really help
okay
let's move on from that
oh thanks Irene gifting to Kimmy
that's kind
okay it's time for gambits and fun
openings and I'll try and break back
into the top 200.
top 150 is very optimistic
Queen F3 this topical line
this is what love you sometimes likes to
play
in G4 or G5
okay
holding on
number seven
I think traps a queen
there's no G4 I guess already Queen H3
there
okay I'll take it
as the final 41 minutes
okay we'll play one of these
oh
so D5 is a resource in combination with
these ideas
bulk
takes I take with Queen
I'm really tempted to play Knight G5
let's set up a smaller mate but
uh yeah this is this is waiting for
lights up a piece maybe I'll still set
up this mother mate
H5
okay setting up the Rook sack
okay
have to take my rage out on someone
let's keep berserking
a couple quick wins there
for gamma time
okay I'll go into this line
this can be a fun one
this is a really fun one
okay White's getting mated in a move or
two
no mercy
thank you Swedish Chef
and your White's just stalling
[Music]
and they start a small break
1.5 years
hey happy 1.5 awkward nights
a pointless calculating probably like 15
moves deep
I couldn't find anything
okay top 180
trying to ride the momentum wave
A4 is if I move
okay so we basically got some version of
a Grand Prix
it looks a little bit suspect for
weights
G1
long term the plan is to play
this and this
that's a good move though
I still want to play C3
Target the D4 Pawn
and eventually D4
coming very soon
so this runs into this with a double
threat
oh no I'm getting fort
Queen D3 was still a resource there
foreign
[Music]
but I also opened that file
I have to look on the right side
and I just want to access ooh
blundering a little bit too much
still kind of playable
not pretty though
calculating D5
I think my best hope is sometimes
scramble
thank you
very cool line takes here here Fork
okay some counter play also a huge time
advantage
and it's looking more and more likely
I'm not going to lose this
[Music]
throughout this
I want to trap The Rook
okay
this Knight is pinned and attacked three
times
okay I'll take it wasn't the cleanest
game but
it was a game
okay double berserk
lunge and opening
this is supposed to not be a great line
for black
foreign
s
[Music]
but position
should be nice
that was a me threat
Our Queen is useful here preparing Rook
B1
I'm the diagonal
um
enabling this
I still can't do that
um
okay another time scramble approaching
foreign
way too slow there
way too slow a little bit too weak too
only berserk mode okay
I'll be disappointing if my opponent
doesn't berserk
what does this username
hey we have the same line as earlier
I feel very misled
foreign
oh no my Knights
if white takes it light will be up two
pieces
but the king will be smack in the center
Queen H4 wait a minute
and queen of six
this probably wasn't the best line
it's still interesting though
basically getting
what a rook rook and jubons for two
pieces
92 is playable
92 maybe Knight C3
okay there's Queen D5
[Music]
probably want to take the bishop soon
also turning F5
thank you
opponent using their full-time
as a very generous move
D belated Christmas present
in the form of a large pork
okay 164.
top 100 requires probably a lot more
points
playing a walrus
got the walrus
let's have some England damage Vibes too
and queen d2's
wow okay so I have this move
painting attacking attacking
I'm being Ultra aggressive here
it might backfire
but
also looks interesting
if Knight B5 it looks very strong I have
Queen A2
and I should probably prevent Knight B5
Maybe
Rook A5
I might end up sacking The Exchange
I might have to
there's Queen B6 though
defending defending
uh yeah that's a threat
[Music]
I think I'll just Castle
I'm trying to Castle my way out of
trouble
I'm still in a lot of trouble hearing
threatening needs
there's some compensation needy
B5 95
foreign
I want to play B4
it's hard to do without a bee Pawn
though
nice gift
foreign
was a little bit too slow there
okay 23 minutes left
I'm gonna try and end strong
we broke again E4 again
Carol Cunningham
been having the sign a decent amount I'm
taking Bishop E5
it's gonna be a tricky line for luck
I'm trapping the bishop
because F6
wow
uh what's Happening Here
bring this and this
E3 is covered by the bishop
opponent misses a rook was attacked
okay
so many presents
felt like Christmas and my birthday
and Hanukkah
and Valentine's Day
okay
another double berserk
all standard grand prix stuff
foreign
much better here though
yeah that didn't do too much
maybe this will do something
[Music]
um
this is a meeting
this meeting wow
okay that was a cool Queen sack oh no my
queen
that's nice
369.
140 seconds
okay playing gabacon
what cabinet are we going to see this
game
oh wow
who's who's the one gamuting
um
really
that's a move
I could tell by the username this would
be a fun game
living up to the expectations
I don't know who's having more fun
though
I've gameted a lot of Pawns
but does that make me a god
let's get a bit more pawns No Maybe
might as well
okay I'm gameting my whole Queen sign
every Pawn lost as a file opened
now where's my comp
this looks like some comp
I don't know if this works
oh that doesn't work
oh why am I gambiting so many things
how like I made it
oh
what to do that's a fun game
more fun for my opponent though
I was too incentivized to Gambit too
many things
okay we'll have one of these again
this looks fun
I'm gameting a little bit too much
but I'm having a fun in the process
um
oh dear
that was not called for I'm down three
Pawns
on the right side
I have two Bishops
what is this madness
is White's Queen trapped white screen is
almost trapped
there's Rook C4
it was very confusing
I like this bishop
all I need to do is get my queen to G2
or each one
foreign
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
okay
I'm gonna try and win the final games
like as quickly as possible
let's see how strong I can finish
this is probably not a good position
it's interesting though
yeah Lock's already doing okay here
the gamuting continues
or the blundering
King C6
a lot of gifts giving this game
wow
whoa
uh where's my meat
here's my mates
it's still not meat
okay
oh these games
136 am I still within range
Keepers working
final stretch
uh the sign
yeah this is a fun line
foreign
was called for
and queen H5 is
likely coming
hi hi
Timmy tall welcome
foreign
[Music]
or is there controlling all these
squares
with the retreating moves
okay
10 minutes left 133
so I would need to reach 400 tournament
points
for top hundred but probably more
they think you have them John Curtis
appreciate the raid
if you're just joining this is the final
10 minutes of the beach has winter
Marathon
I'm trying to win as many games as
quickly
humanly possible
playing some dubious
highly aggressive chess
it's been working in a lot of games
okay going after F2
oh no my Bishop
and Bishop D3 coming
and get away with taking
taking is not called for
yeah that's a queen drop
Queen is still trapped
okay
126. so I need three more berserk wins
for
400 tournament points
foreign
of this opening
at least that one is playing quickly
um
not a great position though
I do want to take the Knight
foreign
position
[Music]
weights tied down to D5 and F4
and now E2
[Music]
um
still a bit tricky though
I don't see how wide starting the Apon
because I'm controlling a with a knight
ah
there was Rook C1 there
okay plenty of time
five minutes left in the tournament
back to tournaments
122.
I think there should be time for
hopefully two more games to count
you know and the opponent doesn't
berserk back this this could be the
final game
and being aggressive as usual
so I've taken away box costing rates
don't want to trade Queens
D1 still on the horizon
[Music]
it's a free Pawn
more free Pawns
hd5
I'm gonna take the Knight and queen B3
and I don't see how lock defends I mean
there's 95
this is completely winning now
I'm hoping for one more game after this
foreign
will definitely count for the tournament
let's double check
okay
one more maybe
maybe one more win from 2500 as well
that would be a nice finish
okay
hey upon berserking too
final game probably
London opening
already nice position
uh
I want to play F5
E6 or F6 coming
Bishop is actually trapped
let's go one more game probably not
pairings are closed okay
almost 1200 friend is strong 106 400
total tournament points 25 200 players
wow that's a lot of players there's it's
not too late to join you can still join
maybe we'll find two more people just
joined final seconds
okay
do I refresh oh no
okay good job Lord ax
with an astounding
one thousand German points
congratulations so I would have needed
to get 600 more points to catch up
thanks everyone for tuning in to and big
shout out to everyone who's watching in
the future on YouTube
who made it through the whole video oh I
was gonna I forgot to like even mention
this
but
I'm very close to hitting 600k on
YouTube this is my current sub number
599 870. need 130 Subs so if you're
watching and you're not subscribed on
YouTube
we do have the YT command okay yeah it's
time to it's time to wrap things up